good girl I'm totally in love with you I
heard you like Raves you like sex in the
city you're cool you're fun age
transcends I just want to hang out with
you and please bring back dance parties
yes and is it true you end up to Sarah
Jessica Parker and you were like I
I'm watching you it was yeah it was a
really bad moment for me just because I
saw her and I ran up and I was going
through a really bad breakup and I was
like Hey I just have to tell you like
I've been watching you and big and it's
like giving me a lot of Hope and she's
like oh that you'll get back together
and I was like no that I Will Survive
that I can like move on from this and
that it'll be okay she's like okay
that's I'm gonna get in my car now